the united kingdom has proclaimed
charles iii as its new king this morning
following the death of his mother queen
elizabeth here's what's going on outside
buckingham palace king charles promised
to follow his mother's inspiring example
britain is observing 10 days of mourning
ahead of the state funeral for the queen
holly williams has the latest from
buckingham palace
good morning while nobody does pageantry
quite like the british it really is
their forte and today it is on full
display as they proclaim their new king
charles iii accompanied by his wife
queen consort camilla and the new heir
to the british throne prince william
king charles swore an oath then the
garter king of arms read the
proclamation from the balcony of saint
james's palace which dates back to the
time of henry viii the sound of state
trumpeters rang out they gave three
cheers for their new king with the
king's guard raising those towering
bare-skinned hats above the head and
there was a royal gun salute charles
became king immediately after his mother
the late queen died on thursday but
today's ceremonies are all about
informing the nation that it has a new
monarch with conventions dating back
generations to a time before people
could use telephones televisions and the
internet to pass on the news
the proclamation will now be repeated at
locations around the country in his
first address to the nation last night
king charles talked about his heartfelt
debt to his mother and vowed to emulate
her he also seemed to offer an olive
branch to his son harry expressing his
love for him and his wife megan and
yesterday we saw king charles and queen
consort camilla get a rapturous welcome
from members of the public here outside
buckingham palace some in the crowd were
heard to say god bless you to their new
king
back to you guys
thank you holly williams you know a lot
can be said about making you know an
entrance into a new seat and it seems
like he's um doing a pretty good job
he's had a long time now obviously
waiting knowing what the future
absolutely as well yeah seems to know
what he's doing